it's been leaked that the edge of
tomorrow is getting a tv series but the
way it got leaked is crazy
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv i'm
movie channel
[Music]
now this is a slightly complicated one
but basically the edge of tomorrow
starring tom cruise and emily blunt was
always supposed to have a sequel there
was a script for the movie they've been
trying to make it basically ever since
the original came out which did actually
get really good reviews from the critics
it's rotten tomato score was up in the
mid 90s and it actually made 370 million
dollars worldwide doug lyman has said he
absolutely adores the script for the
sequel and would love to make it and
this has been sort of going on and on
and on scheduling emily blunt and tom
cruise together to get in the movie was
one big problem but then basically emily
blunt came out in may 2001 and said look
this film is going to cost warner
brothers an absolute fortune maybe a
little bit too much
so it's been shelved but warner brothers
have now decided they're going to make a
tv series now i think that'll be a hard
reboot basically i think they will start
again i think they'll pretend like the
film didn't happen and they will just do
a tv series based on the events and
based on the um plot of the sequel
that's planned and i think that could be
a really good idea the cgi and
production value of this is up to a
level now that i think they could
produce something really exciting if
they really put their minds to it
but as i said
how old do we know this because warner
brothers have not officially announced
it well this is a crazy one this
basically is all down to village
roadshow and their legal battle with
warner brothers over matrix
resurrections
so
village roadshow is actually suing
warner brothers because they are not
very happy they co-produced matrix
resurrections with warner brothers but
warner brothers decided to release
matrix resurrections on hbo max the same
day was released as cinemas now
village road shows say this breached
their contract and actually cost them
money they co-produced it but obviously
they don't get any money from hbo max
they get the bulk of their money from
the box office the box office that was
slaughtered by it being released on hbo
max the same day they claim the reason
why matrix resurrections did so poorly
at the box office was solely down to
this decision
nothing to do with the fact that it's
not a very good film in places i
actually like bits i don't like others
but anyway that's a different video but
in the lawsuit they have also mentioned
other projects that they have with
warner brothers they mentioned the
charlie the chocolate factory movie now
they co-produced the more recent charlie
chocolate factory film the johnny depp
version
and they're going to do basically um the
sequel for that but warner brothers are
arguing that it's not really a sequel so
they don't have to give village roadshow
any money
for the choice so i'm not happy about
that
they also then mention in article 20 of
the lawsuit about this tv series warner
brothers co-produced the original movies
with village roadshow so they're saying
we co-own the rights warner brothers are
saying that only actually matters for
the movie rights we on the tv rights you
don't deserve any money
village road sir don't agree
so this is going to start a massive
legal battle and we're gonna have to see
whether this tv show ever actually gets
made because we don't know what stage
we're at within production and we don't
really know anything more than what's in
this legal document but what we do know
is village roadshow i'm not happy about
it and unless some sort of deal can be
struck between them and warner brothers
it might actually hamper not only this
project but several others
or warner brothers are going to have to
give village roadshow a crapload of
money
so what do you think guys is a tv show
at the edge of tomorrow something you
want to see is it something that would
excite you because personally i love the
movie i generally think it's tom
cruise's last actual decent movie i
don't think he's done anything of any
worth ever since
i haven't seen top gun 2 yet but i'm not
expecting great deal from that either i
think there are lots of layers to that
tv series potentially and i think it
could really work out but what do you
think please get in the comments
also what do you think though about
these movies getting the same day
release on streaming platforms and how a
lot of studios are now sparking legal
battles over it disney plus did the same
with couple of projects and you know
they use it to push the streaming
platform on in this never-ending battle
for supremacy in the world of streaming
but it really is destroying cinema in
the process is that something that
worries you as much as it worries me
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out you
can also become a fully fledged side
tracker and support the channel hit that
join button
as always guys please stay safe i'll see
you next time
foreign